now to the latest look at global press
freedom according to reporters without
borders
the outlook has never looked so bleak a
new report
says the pandemic has made the work of
journalists harder
reporters without borders annual index
singles out scandinavian countries
as having the freest media norway and
finland
come out on top now germany is no longer
in the leading
nations but is well ahead of the uk now
some of the world's
largest countries rank much lower india
and china for example at number 142
and 147 respectively and last is the
small east african country of eritrea
falling
this year behind north korea
and let's get more from christian mayor
he is the
executive director of the german branch
of reporters without borders good to
have you on the program christian why is
the pandemic
making the work of journalists harder
the pandemic is a global thing and all
over the world we see
governments failing governments
sometimes even spreading
disinformation on on on on
medicine or something all over the world
and journalists are claiming a
questioning actually
the efficacy of efficiency of
governmental politics
the the failing policies of governments
fighting the pandemics
and whenever they question this actually
they are persecuted just for
seeking the truth and holding
governments accountable and this
is happening both in democracies and
dictatorships
christian which country concerns you the
most
this year i mean at the
really bottom of our index there are as
in the last years north korea eritrea
turkmenistan these are the countries
which actually totally control
information who persecute journalists
who
arbitrarily detain journalists very
often for long years for many years
and where press freedom almost not
exists
and what's gone wrong in germany uh
germany is no longer among the top
nations
in germany unfortunately we really see a
huge rise
of violence against journalists mainly
happening
at the rallies against the corona
measures
in germany we have we registered
fifth times more violent against
journalists
who who covered these protests and
unfortunately german police
not always protected the work of
journalists in a very good way and this
led actually to the decrease of germany
in the index and which led actually that
germany is not
over not not any more declared as good
but only is fairly good all right that
is christian mayor he is the
executive director of reporters without
borders
germany thank you christian
you